and we're back in our series a more
perfect union we aim to show that what
unites us as Americans is far greater
than what divides us as the corona virus
continues to spread neighbors are
forming mutual aid groups to help each
other out the concept is not new but
it's made a huge difference in places
badly affected by the pandemic places
like New York City Eric Barnett shows us
how one family in Queens created a
massive aid network as helping hundreds
of people avians op Ellis has lived in
Astoria for 22 years
most of her neighbors were strangers
until the pandemic brought them together
in one of the hardest hit regions in the
country people are banding together
volunteering for grocery runs and other
errands to help the most vulnerable I
immediately reached my apartment I need
medication there really yeah that's what
we're here for
it's been a lifeline for people like
Alissa Weinberger who lives with the
autoimmune disease lupus it really
helped me keep my independence and my
sense of normalcy what began with flyers
and texts has evolved into the historia
mutual aid network I said to them you
know I'm a nurse can I help in any way
I'd love to help and they're like
absolutely volunteer Marie eliris became
a neighbor in need after she and her
husband contracted kovat 19 leaving
their 11 year old daughter to care for
them both we were bedridden
we were very weak I was shocked how it
can hit you like a ton of bricks how
much help did you receive from the group
you were previously volunteering I was
thankful that they were out there when I
was first really sick with like
temperatures spiking to 102 103 four
days in a row I remember the one lady
who I had asked her for cleaning wipes
for us but I ended up using them to like
keep cool and I really think that helped
me bring the temperature down
and her husband bounced it back but her
sister Anna who also contracted the
virus couldn't she little older with
some underlying health conditions and
unfortunately despite their best efforts
she passed away this mutual aid network
was an idea born out of this pretty
nondescript building here in Astoria a
woman who lives here realized the
neighbor needed groceries so she took
what she could out of a fridge and
hand-delivered it that good deed has
cascaded into hundreds of neighbors
helping each other we know we've been
able to assist over 600 of our neighbors
they've asked our support for at least
900 tasks and we've been able to do that
because we have an incredible network of
almost 900 now volunteers Miriam and her
husband Ross created the Astoria mutual
aid Network coughing out a deep sense of
community for their seven-year-old
daughter Emma
even though the New York metro area is
densely populated that's often the case
that you don't know who lives right next
door
yeah for me to truly get to know my
community and the members of that
community in a very direct and real way
has been incredibly powerful what do you
think will be the lasting impact of what
you're doing my hope is that we're not
waiting to go back to what we call
normal but that this experiences helps
us shape what we want the new normal to
be leading with compassion and humanity
and recognizing that we have the agency
to create a change and to demand the
change within our communities that we
hope to see CBS this morning
Errol Barnett New York Wow Bravo Errol
and Bravo to the Astoria mutual age this
is one of those moments where you wonder
could this be a longer term change in
the way we help one another instead of
turning to private services turn to your
neighbors turn to your friends they're
there two guys built something special